san francisco mayor london breed
learning the lesson the hard way after
defending the police force by 120
million dollars in 2020. we remember
that now after a series of insane smash
and grab thefts which are not slowing
down all of a sudden she wants to get
tough on crime listen it's time
that the reign of criminals who are
destroying our city it is time for it to
come to an end
and it comes to an end
when we take the steps
to be more aggressive
with law enforcement more aggressive
with the changes in our policies
and less tolerant
of all the
that has destroyed our city
where did this come from nancy pelosi
who represents san francisco can't seem
to figure out what is actually behind
the crime surge
it's it's absolutely outrageous you know
obviously it cannot continue
but the fact is that there is an
attitude of
lawlessness in our country that springs
from i don't know where
maybe you do
and we cannot have that lawlessness
become the norm
you empty the prisons you don't
prosecute anything that doesn't result
in the death of somebody else and of
course you defund and defame the cops
here's their reforms the tenderloin
crackdown was just one of four things
they're going to be doing the other
three securing emergency police funding
amending our surveillance ordinance so
law enforcement can interrupt crime in
real time excuse me put that down they
weren't able to say that before
disrupting the illegal street sales of
stolen goods so is this the beginning of
a ripple effect jesse soon we're going
to have a philadelphia uh uh d.a
speaking out mayor speaking out and then
new york we got a new one coming in and
then chicago and then los angeles is
this going to be a ripple effect every
city will reach a breaking point they'll
reach it differently in different cities
philly's reaching him pretty quickly
otto van bismark
brian famously said
what
bond
vaughn it was van morrison i think i
said vaughn yeah
fools learn from their mistakes wise men
learn from other people's mistakes
london breed's a fool she's got a cool
name cool cool name sounds like a
villain in a batman movie but she's a
fool because everybody knows you defund
the police and do what they do and
you're going to have a crime surge you
can't keep doing this without expecting
the same outcome i blame the san
francisco voters you put a fool in
office fool's going to do what a fools
do right you know you're going to vote
for people that make stupid decisions
they have destroyed a crown jewel right
of california it is now basically san
francisco a tech mecca surrounded by a
filthy moat of degeneracy lawlessness
criminals and a 549 team and drugs and
and you know what happened here i think
what really happened a bunch of business
people came and said we're going to get
out if you don't fix this and her poll
numbers obviously are going to take
ahead and she's not going to be a
national politician if she's going to
ruin this city look what happened to de
blasio he tried to run for president he
got laughed out of the room uh and he'll
get left out as governorship too so uh
dan just one is this a one-off one
speech that it or do you see something
happening beyond this something happened
there was a straw that broke the camel's
back so it wasn't when the walgreens
were being looted uh for the last year
or two that we've been showing that it
was when the high-end stores started
getting looted and so i assume these are
the business owners and also some of her
donors probably saying
the city you're going to lose everything
if you don't do something you're in that
contract but she's got a problem and
that the uh prosecutor is the one he
he's in under a recall but that doesn't
happen for another several months and if
even if it would pass i don't know if it
would so that's really the problem that
she needs to fix the last thing i would
say is many of these um well i shouldn't
say many
often you have seen
women politicians when they get into the
position
of something being tough that they like
want to curse like that to sound tougher
and i think that it actually diminishes
their power and their dignity very good
point uh just real quick for specific
for you judge i watched william bratton
one hour ago on this channel and he said
i don't care about the mayors i don't
care about the police chiefs i only care
about the da's well that's exactly the
point and as a former d.a myself what i
can tell you is when this mayor said
that she said she basically said i hope
that our d.a will prosecute she said we
expect law enforcement to react the way
he should and i hope the d.a will
prosecute as the mayor she's got some
skin in this game and she can force the
d.a
in ways that you and i can't figure out
to prosecute and make no mistake
lawlessness begets lawlessness what's
going on around the wharf in in san
francisco where fentanyl is killing kids
they're not necessarily overdosing but
they're dying because it's murder uh and
in addition to they're selling stolen
goods and counterfeit goods you've got
all of that crime in that area then it's
only going to get worse and i really
believe number one she's either stupid
to have signed on to defunding the
police a year ago or she is only into
the ideology so much that left-wing
ideology that she doesn't care about the
people of her city right so she either
believes that all police are racist
serial murderers or she doesn't give a
damn about it she seems to have changed
her mind or or she changed her mind
sincerely because she understood finally
how long it took a year
sometimes it takes people a year 456
people were killed in san francisco i
think when i interrupted and i think
that it was when that security guard the
cop ex-cop got shot outside one of those
stores uh when the the gang looters were
there but the number one job of
government is to keep people safe
whatever her aspirations remember i
think kamala harris the d.a of san
francisco also whatever and she was a
crime buster she was a real buster when
she was uh the d.a there not really
she had a very good reputation the city
was safe they weren't all the homeless
around
so i'm okay with uh with london breed as
jesse points out greatest name in uh in
uh mayoral politics uh you know i'm i'm
okay with her being born again let her
be boring and let them all be born again
and you want to see action i i want to
see frosty i want to see people being
held responsible for the crimes they
commit against society society being
safe from people who are degenerate and
dysfunctional and greedy and you know
finally i just know republicans have so
much to they have so much money flowing
to their party they never take a run a
little serious run at these da positions
they don't take runs at the mayor
positions all i hear about is every
major city while there's no
infrastructure for the republicans to
run so therefore people have no choice
but unfortunately i i'd have to leave it
there maybe because it was such a great
point i've done foundation you can
stretch it out there right thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else